on today's beauty talk my guest is the
lipstick queen herself
none other than the fabulous we Torah
obviously the red lip is your signature
look so what's the secret to the Rita
red lip it makes your lips just juicy I
mean every time I saw a red lip on any
female whether it was Marilyn Monroe or
my mother I always just saw them in a
different kind of light and it made me
want to be glamorous beauty and glamour
is what women have as power and I and I
like to use that power so it's more than
just a red lip it's it's like me beauty
why would you pack moisturizing cream
and a face mist
oh it's essential I always have to
refresh wake up I use that a Mac
refresher the other signature yeah you
have is your hair no it's the blonde I
mean what is it about you know for you
being blonde I'm naturally a brunette so
for me a blonde is a massive difference
anyway
what you put in it you put like if
specific I've used everything from food
to like olive oil to even bigs
apparently beer helps you like close the
ends so you love nail art is this what
you're into right now because it like a
king of me yeah it's not like a
monochrome thing I honestly didn't know
why I wants to do too with the nails I
just saw a really nice kind of sample of
all these things and I want it to just
be as monochrome very tailored as
possible today's shoot was about being
detailed and being really sexy and
effortless they want to talk to you
about your collaboration your new
perfume collaboration why have you
always loved fragrance or is this
something new
the perfume world is new for me but
smelling good is really important I mean
as you can see everything that I'm doing
that we can do to decorate as a woman
like nails smell hair makeup clothes
underwear everything I use I use the
tools that we get given you know I mean
so for me doing a perfume was kind of
the next step to being fabulous did they
kind of say right here's a few samples
and you got to kind of choose what you
like today explain the concept you know
my NY being about New York and it
having to be the city in a bottle and
that's where it came from as a little
you know New York for me is a really
special place that's right you know went
into the studio for the first time
that's very well signed that's where
things happened for me it made sense and
it was a young fresh fragrance and a
smell awesome and the bottle is awesome
and you know there was no reason for me
not to do you work fragrance in you
onstage
yes yes my ritual is I sip tea listen to
music we apply my lipstick about 17
million times and then I spray perfume
on I feel like it's my responsibility
when I'm on set to give people and
motivation you've got to make sure
everyone's comfortable so they work to
their best thank you so thank you and
thank you very much so perfume a quiet
the whole every pounding